I have not played classical chess in a
long time been playing a lot of blitz
some bullets also there is there's close
to 80,000 people on me chess right now
so I think when tournaments started it
sometimes takes a bit more than a bit
longer than usual
so this is going to be a bit different
than than usual as well because I'm
playing in Zen mode and I'm gonna plan
to do this for all my games d3 so I have
no idea who I'm playing it could be
playing a complete noob but usually in
the beginning of tournaments play c5
here
yeah the first round of tournaments
usually you play someone closer to your
own rating hello to everyone
yeah shout out to BCP and Retta ban or
the the first two in the chat very weird
name is back
IAM the illusion InfoSec Gareth Ryder
Ryder how's everyone doing
diamond cutter welcome back for all I
know I could be playing one of you
whites already very perplexed the idea
of c5 is just to get some Sicilian setup
I get from if efore then we'll have
probably some closed Sicilian if g3 yeah
so it's gonna be some sort of I guess
closed Sicilian Kings Indian attack whoa
its pol boertie without vowels I want to
put O's in there because that's that's
Fiddler's main username thank you pull
boertie gifting subs gifting five subs
to Yanni of kz d web 30 to Lowell for
life dark teddy and what is in the name
thanks so much let's play I think I'll
just stick with kind of a dragon setup I
mean usually when I play Sicilian I play
the silence with you 6 and d5 but I'll
try and play something solid something
classical chess we've how's it going
just meet in the house to the we'd have
the we'd command hello to Ken Matthew G
L rasa door yeah so many people hello to
ever and I didn't say hello to Felix
chess nightbot Robson 81 Robson 81 are
you related to to the ultimate Robson
the REA Robson I played Bishop g7 and
just sat upon and then Queen a5 there's
really no need I'm just gonna play g6
I mean it's kind of an intriguing
variation if it were a correspondence
chess maybe I I calculate that but in g6
doesn't move all almost playing like
anyway so no reason to take like two
minutes to calculate and the general
setup is vision of g7 I have six
castling or B a B 5 B 4 whoa another sub
and 5 more subs be Basu sobbing a tier 1
first time sub and mathias SE gifting
subs also gifting 5 subs said BLT bacon
bacon lettuce tomato 1089 air Jon cut
furred latte tonic and state-o main
almost read that as stadle mania main as
a state that I have not been to Akash
how's it going
Oh Charlotte Akash a VIP in MVP also a
streamer I saw you're gonna do a charity
stream
some point I think Sunday right maybe
I'll try and if I remember I'll try and
organize some raid Oh what does Zen mode
okay so Zen mode I can't really I'm not
gonna switch it off and on because it
would reveal who I'm playing but Zen
mode basically hides the ponent hides
the raining hides your previous score so
it's a it's a nicer way to focus I can
also maybe shift the board down you
actually fix okay let's start with
Bishop g7 make a new scene for Zen mode
it's just kind of a cleaner less
distracting review of what's going on
this is interesting this is a position
I've I played from the white side it's
kind of close Sicilian setup White has a
few ideas eventually Bishop h6 how this
thanks for the bits there's also some
idea each for which can come at various
points I don't think I'm afraid of okay
the the move I want to play is Knight f6
I don't think I'm afraid of this
but not sure how I would respond to it
because if I Castle then there's this
move but it has to be okay like 94 even
take some night g4s I could calculate
906 Bishop h6 castling h4 takes takes 94
the Queen has to move and then something
like each five and I'm just ahead and
development at some point I want to pay
my d4 I think this is a type of moments
if Y wants to play Bishop h6 white
should be the one thinking and I should
just conserve time is pull Portis
fiddler I don't think so there used to
be I used to have a twitch viewer with
the handle Peters fiddler who is clearly
not fiddler wise n mood just to mix
things up I did this a few days ago and
it kind of adds another another layer in
terms of I guess trying to figure out my
opponent rating so by the end of the
scheme I'll try and guess how strong my
opponent is maybe 94-94 I always have to
like be ready for take stakes 92 which i
think is okay because IV v h3 h3 is
prophylaxis against this move
you know thinking this the dream would
be this and then this I'm also thinking
like 90 night 94 realistically white
would play Bishop g2 castling 92 and
then e 5 think that looks nice
there's some tactic if like castles in
that line there's Bishop takes h3 and
then the forking possibility f3 is a
potential weakness it seems kinda really
to play this move but I mean White's
playing slowly so why not try and apply
pressure this is not a new feature if
you want to activate it there's two ways
you can go into your your system your
your your preferences and it's under
game display and Zen mode also like
during a game just press Z on the
keyboard
Aakash gifting a subbed Yorkin AAB
thanks Aakash appreciate that yeah
there's a lot of like hidden keyboard
shortcuts within me Ches
so Z Z activates sun-moon F F will flip
the board right yeah it's weird looking
from the points perspective biscuit
fiends also something yeah so honestly
I'm guessing my opponents probably like
2200 just because it's the first round
of the tournament and I get paired to
someone close to my rating actually
forget what my rating is maybe I can
guess my rating - I think it's like 23
something I don't play me chess
classical too often
could you play one game with the board
flipped um
[Music]
maybe but not right now might say that
for another time I feel like that would
that would throw people off that would
probably throw me off okay so if I was
my initial plan the thing about me five
is that the eventual plans f5 so my
night will probably have to move at some
points
but yeah so well I was saying earlier
not sure how many people followed but if
castling Bishop takes h3 it's a somatic
tactic with another three ideas looming
I can't do it I couldn't do it right
away because rook takes h3 F for a while
so White's trying to to apply pressure
probably not a bad move does pose some
questions because I find might be coming
but a five probably can just take
so a few moves come to mind one move is
just b5 which might be a pawn sacrifice
like b5 takes takes takes and Knight
takes but then I probably win the pawn
back would be 2 and the simple idea of
b5 s to play d4 Oh f4 also kind of
prepares White's to castle because I'm
the rook would cover f3 and I don't have
Bishop takes h3
this move also comes to mind I teach
five the idea of trying to just pressure
also unleashing the bishop in the event
of G 4 I would take
there's also some idea let's say 9 h5
castling simply to take here because the
night would be defended and say pawn to
X and then f5 the thing is like these
ideas this idea does not combine well
with this idea because the diagonal is
open so work could be a might me might
be necessary at some point now our idea
is crossing my mind which is d5 or even
to take first like there's lots of
options here I could consider taking
here which is interesting
[Music]
it's kind of tempting just to play b5v
four and just let white do what whatever
they want to do b5 castling before 91
[Music]
I could trade
[Music]
this move is also crossing my mind takes
just questioning how light recapture is
assumed with pawn looking briefly at
this but that doesn't work so takes
takes 9h five the thing is if I take
immediately take some night each five
there's a media idea of Queen h4 even if
caste and Queen h4 still comes attacking
the pawn if ever this I just got
initiative it looks yeah more I look at
this move the more I like it and then I
just abandon this whole b5 fan
it looks so unusual because I I allow
light to strengthen the center I trade
off the center pawn but I guess I should
also calculate takes I think that's a
huge concern though if Knight takes
Knight takes is also a move
actually night takes could be a bigger
problem hmm
I'm considering taking pivotal juncture
in time
okay so I'm not like like I would like
this move if if I knew why it would take
back with pawn but takes back with
Knight as some is actually a bit
annoying because there's less support
for this night maybe there's a night
97-95 ideas I could also maybe it makes
sense to start with this idea of taking
and then just trading which was one of
my initial ideas okay I didn't calculate
this fully but some I think this does
the most the most good in the position
very multi-purpose pressures these
points opens up the Queen opens up the
bishop as well as the pawn so it keeps
my whole thing keep my options open
oh gee cook says entertainment for all
my remaining work hours how many people
are hardworking right now and just
watching me as work yeah for the for
anyone who asks what scent though it is
hopefully someone can respond maybe even
make a Zen mode command but yeah it
should be self-explanatory given I can't
see my point or the reading yeah I was
gonna shift them going down just a
little bit
good even in larger the board to do
people like that larger board and why
not okay so pond takes
um there's really just two options here
both of them yeah let's stick with pong
just rely on intuition and this kind of
looked interesting but I like keeping a
center pond and likes very well
reinforced the D files open the bishop
will develop naturally and this move was
not not a move I was most afraid of
looking good okay love the large board
yes especially I'm sure people watching
on mobile especially with those like
normal-sized phones not those plus size
phones hopefully see things more clearly
though Alden is in first place with six
points
yeah I'm not I guess I haven't clarified
this but I'm not trying to win the
tournament I'm just trying to like play
instructive games and hopefully play
some clean games so black cap or white
castles which yeah looks solid
I would like to wait to look for tactics
because there's some some targets but
everything's solid for lights
g4 might be coming actually and there's
this move to consider but Knight takes I
think I'll just play Bishop e6
and by far the most normal move some
idea just just improving Queen d7
if g4 I'll probably have to move back
though there might be there might be
takes in 94 if I force a knight takes
neither for it's assumed takes takes
promise Bishop takes c5 I was thinking I
wouldn't this but it's too many things
hanging so I'll move back
for a moment I thought I'd blundered and
I may this may have been I might be in
trouble actually here because there's a
smooth
trying to calculate
yeah it's gonna gonna actually cause
some headaches
I just assumed this is my only move not
realizing why it's gonna start applying
pressure there's some interesting
tactics for tactical ideas if this I can
play h6 and it takes takes takes I have
an I take c2 you can get pretty weird
pretty quickly that's probably good for
white though
I'm wondering if I just got careless
like I played the natural move now I'm
beginning to kind of regret this because
I won't have a move like 96 but okay
White's taking time yeah so I mean the
good thing is that I can't add another
attacker immediately I'm actually not
sure what White's threatening
I mean whites just trying to tie me down
this might be the main plan
and for the time being I can't really
relieve the pin considering b5 going
with my my original idea was if ever it
takes I take with Queen check and then
then just move my knight later
an idea of b5 is to essentially kick the
night make them I move somewhere to take
on you two and then either play Queen D
for each six with the Queen no longer on
d2
so the ultimate question is what to do
I kind of like b5 I hope I'm not missing
the threats but I mean worst case
scenario I have h6 and zakopane and then
try and fight let's play b5 oh but beef
okay so b5 I just realized if takes
takes king h1 the be pawns hanging and
the knights hanging I have this moved in
that line thanks Matthias I'm trying but
it's difficult
yeah b5 this could actually be a problem
this one was also across from my mind c4
actually c4 has a sneaky idea to it
but not sure if it's sneaky enough
honey any move like c4 I have to
anticipate abrooke f2 and then takes
like takes oh I have an idea
yeah let's play c4 in general I mean
this is a somatic break with the
structure but c4 also does something
really important which I don't know if I
want to say immediately just in the vet
my opponents watching because I think
it's possible for a white to overlook
something and then just give me a nice
position but we'll find out eventually
anyway yeah when I I should note that
when I got kind of sucked into the
position and fall deep in thought I kind
of figure out about the chats but thanks
for people who are sticking around shout
out to Thomas regular viewer regular
streamer we have a Thomas command and
yeah everyone else yeah I still have to
at some point guess my opponents rating
no one's playing well though I mean I
think 2,200 is is a fair guess probably
in the range of 22 to 2,400
Hey wish I had aces or wish' dayses
thanks for subbing for seven months and
I takes d4
so this crossed my mind and I just
assumed it takes now I can reveal that
the point of c4 was to prepare Queen b6
and there are lines where this diagonal
would be very useful but yeah now I
think just takes the king either the
king will move I'll play 97 like when
God doesn't get trapped pawns always
defended or Bishop e3 I'll just move
back my with my queen I'll be to d6
again there's a slide takes takes takes
takes and we both are left with bad
bishops
yes my point was stockfish that would be
pretty cruel let's talk fish looking to
humiliate me again let's play play this
smooth also nice comment from just rich
recently got into chess and started
watching seamless Chess Club nice yeah I
have probably have about ten videos on
the st. Louis Chess Club YouTube channel
that was my my introduction to to just
online chess no not my introduction to
my online chess brand I should say let's
play let's play Queen d6 only move now
yeah there's tension mixologist says I
like bad bishops is that your problem
it's not a good problem to like bad
dishes but no matter how bad a bishop is
you can always get better if the
position opens up like if this pollen
goes away this Bishop is just a dragon
breathing fire
[Music]
I'm not taking challenges I'm in
complete Zen though no distractions Li
Chiao hides everything including like
the the the top user bar so I can't even
I can't do anything I can't type my
moves I can't change the sound effects
or the board style I check my messages
even hides a time control I think the
time control is 20 plus 10 so of
increments yeah there's not going to be
any like dirty flag in the stream
hey see ghost watch watched chest states
yeah that's a documentary
I'm featured in I was produced in
2012-2013 a long time ago if I had to
evaluate the position I don't know I
feel like I would be biased and just say
that blacks doing well I mean it seems
relatively equal but I think I would
prefer black because after the Train
whites gonna be left with slightly less
preferable structure like in anyway
these pawns are traded I'll be left with
to pawn islands very healthy parlance
white will be left with either a
structure with three pawn islands like
this or if white takes a swale I will
have three pawns like this right dozen
I'll win back the pawn and this is what
I want especially like given the the
nature of the pin earlier I thought
there could have been a lot more trouble
and my original calculation which I
didn't share was rook f2 takes takes and
then just Queen b6 and Queen b6 gets out
of the pin and defends a knight
indirectly because it pins a rook so if
takes takes or what can't take and life
would have been pretty good I think also
attacks upon so it's thinking
remaining pretty level on time did the
arena freeze so frozen Rosen is back
that's unfortunate
drinking the Alaskan hand-mixed tea and
I added too much water so you like brew
it inside the cup
anyway 95 might be if I have a tax my
queen attacks the pond kind of I don't
think White's threatening really to take
so first impression is Queen here and
that b5 is definitely the most kind of
direct move so queen c6 if 9 takes a 7 I
have Queenie for essentially trapping
the night I mean there's Queen off -
there's b3 b3 out of 26 let's say b3
Queen a6 Queen off - yeah probably
I can I can answer that momentarily but
let me just if you just address this
position it's getting getting a little
bit weird
I've Queen b8 as well the queen bee
there's takes if I take here white takes
here basically defending the knight I
could take the rook but that's it's not
good for me
here here I could also just take and
play b6 that looks very simple let's
play queen c6 that's another situation
where I should not spend all my time
calculating I should just make whites
white decide whether or not to take it's
probably just too risky what was the
question
over Iban also thanks for subbing for
two months a streamer is rated below
2000
yeah Golda story started streaming as
like a complete beginner and now she's
she's really close to 1600 on chess calm
and out of all the chests streamers she
probably has like the most like visually
attractive just in terms of the stream
layout and the overlays the color scheme
just the branding is really on point but
I think I was checking the last last few
days there's also many new chests
streamers like popping up a few days ago
there I think there were at least 40 or
50 people streaming chests at the same
time I was like peak hour is like maybe
1 or 2 p.m. Central Time
it wasn't great to see
[Music]
yeah Joe Brune Joe Brunei actually
helped i helped him set up his stream
because i think he streams from a mac
still and he reached out to me so his
back when i was streaming from my mac
and then within the past
yeah within the past week I've been
helping like three different friends get
their stream set up ASA or a Dom a4 I
said I was about to say a six so this is
a move that immediately comes to mind
that looks just completely logical just
make the night move
there's this kind of lingering tension
between the pawns I think the goal is to
play rook want to play roof d8 and rook
da Knights e5 I mean the rooks belong
here in here Bishop g5 can be met with
f6 it makes a bishop even more sad this
point I don't really care about the the
happiness of this bishop
can I be hired as a chess coach yeah I
have so I have not been open to new
students I have a very long waiting list
of people that signed up through my
website looking to take lessons so I'm
trying to like think of how to how to
still offer like one-on-one sessions
without without completely filling up my
schedule it's it's a kind of weird
dilemma because there's so much demand
but yeah I mean twitch and YouTube are a
bit more scalable especially when it
comes to teaching
but it's very possible I might get
around to like having opening myself up
to mini-lessons
I'll definitely be brainstorming over
the coming weeks especially because I
mean as of yesterday the candidates got
canceled or got the postponed so now I
have a lot more free time during the
candidates I was working like 10 to 12
hour workdays wait the term and just
ended or your talk about the candidates
hopefully not not this we chest Paschal
tournaments Oh technical issues no oh no
wait the tournament ended no that arena
did it really end I probably could take
some responsibility because like I
tweeted that I was gonna stream it and
probably probably everyone on Twitter
saw it and they flooded leach s oh the
pairings crashed no that's so sad
well this okay so this will be the only
game I guess maybe Queen off - yeah
let's try and stay focused and then I'll
address whatever technical issues but so
far the game is still underway Queen I
choose a good move applying pressure to
this Bishop defends also this kind of
annoying idea also prevents Knight c5
Queen knife to use a very good move the
problem is 95 I can't really take it
yeah sounds like a lyrics some song
and 95 is gonna be threatening a lot of
annoying things too I was feeling good
just like a a move ago and now I'd
probably rather be white
now this Bishop has more influence this
Knight is terribly misplaced so I
probably have to rearrange things I
could play this move actually but this
move again runs into Misha g5 wondering
if it makes sense to eventually
sacrifice on d5 I'm probably not I'm
probably gonna have to allow the knight
to come in and then just play around it
somehow but these these moves don't work
unfortunately if I take that doesn't do
anything so I was thinking about taking
and playing this move or maybe not I
faded right away
95 maybe like King h8 does not look
right though
I mean there's some idea also just to
take and play the Queen d6 and then if
95 I'll have time to take and play raka
fades I think that's the way to go it
seems like a very unusual setup because
the Queen the Queen is kind of leading
the action but there's no clear way to
attack the Queen for white
there's no this move not might be five
and I got off the open C file - so white
wants to play this move yeah that's
probably a good decision and my Knights
gonna have to move you need this move
might be eight it looks really sad but
it's probably necessary I'm just worried
about this should be six Bishop e6 rook
d7 is Bishop c5 I have to rely on
intuition
so d5 of takes takes I have enough to
find a guy for four things covering d4y
when we have three yeah this was kind of
a difficult move to play him but the
Knights so much happier here so it
doesn't block the rook controls this
potential outpost square and then d7 can
be used for my rook it's all about
trying to harmonize the pieces Brian
Brian says I've been getting these crazy
restricted positions all week yeah
though sometimes you just have to deal
with it work with the space that you've
got
[Music]
this should see five so I can't play
this because of this
so it's either Queen d7 oh yeah I mean
Queen c6 defeats the purpose of this I'm
a little bit worried that um I don't
want to say too much yeah I was a bit
worried about this move because now d4
is is looming you probably work out
fades over defend f7 d4 is very playable
I'll have a few options I can play
Bishop c4 or even Bishop e3 could be
interesting Bishop d3 d2 then Bishop c4
very important to stay focused on the
phones time if I get one more tempo
knight c6 everything kind of become
solved white might play this move I
could play this move and then just
repeat and then it's an instance I kind
of wish I would know my pawns reading
[Music]
this is kind of a double-edged move even
if White's like even in the worst case
or I take everything the work comes here
I just move over because there's a 95 in
the end though that's kind of unpleasant
but then the Queen come in 9 of 16 g7 I
don't know so question is do I play a
bishop move or do I know do I just take
a 95 s coming
actually an interesting idea also this
sac which I forgot about that that it's
probably no good vision b3 probably only
helps white a lesser is Bishop III roti
to take steaks and then this move
I'm not sure I go with this line it
takes and then thought was just like
Queenie 7 and in the event of 95 I'll
just try and weather the storm
it's a very long game to start the
tournament
okay so Queenie seven
it's a whole idea I want to find like to
use a clip tempo
expecting this move I'll take imagine
pawn takes and then Queen d6 now I'm
realizing that could just be upon wants
to draw while probably not I'm realizing
some issues with this
Queen d6 is a little bit problematic
I should probably accept the draw but
that would just be a bad ending to
what's been an interesting game so let's
fight
for 18 seconds what increment will help
I'd use this
you know Queen off six I was more scared
of Rica for so I can take in 97 its
imbalance like white houses pawn White
has obviously more space more active
rooks but the goal is to consolidate and
then try to turn this pawn into a
witness had d6 is coming which is a
little bit painful so I probably want to
activate activate ASAP
Brooksie - this would be the dream just
dominate the seventh rank or the second
rank and the Knights not a bad block
hater the knight would much rather be
here but okay I can do I can do some
work so probably be six
I mean what else to do there's maybe
five maybe six
probably the rook wants to be here I'll
be kind of some nice formation of
Defense it's a three result game
anything's possible
I'd say objectively White's still
probably better but it's becoming tricky
to play for both sides I think it would
help to trade a pair of rooks
if all the rocks come off the board
blacks very close to winning because my
king will just come here I'll win the
pawn eventually and that'll just be up
upon so whites advantage lies within the
fact that I'm still kind of passive
that's a decent move they don't take any
King f8 there's also this no let's play
this first
I mean the dream would be this game
Hakeem here but it's not easy to cross
the e-file there's another planet a 695
but g5 could stop that
or even if I achieve this g5 I would
break that town lights also getting low
on time I mean my rook has like some
infiltration squares that move I think I
can I can come around yeah I was holding
off on saying d6 would be a bad move
it looks logical to prepare this but
rookie 7 I'll take I'll defend the
Knights so I'm winning the pawn
and whites on the verge of flagging this
engine could still take a lot of work to
win okay
so Brooke c8 coming or rook c7 that's a
matter of technique let's start with a
five just put the pawns on dark squares
okay before I think I'll take I'd be
okay if if everything on the queenside
gets gets traded
point 95 there's a lot of potential here
to like plan tonight's on one of the
darks words
yeah so this is a case where I want to
play f6 but there's g5 so maybe this
move in 93
ideal nineth for expecting a five
actually don't know like the objective
evaluation if assuming after the trade
this is supposed to be winning for luck
I assume it's gonna be very unpleasant
for white interesting so I could just
attack the bishop and the pawn bishop
here it's the only way to defend the
bishop in the pawn but then rookie - Wow
or tea - okay as easier than expected so
I'm guessing 2250 as my poems reading
just kind of crumbled in time pressure
extra piece and extra pawn more than
enough to win whoa 24:58 but provisional
interesting so wait the turn the
tournament looks to be underway maybe Li
Chiao saved it
hey Samsonite's 1000 bits oh well you
wanted to switch it back I think
Samsonite's yeah that was a hard-fought
game ambient chess and Commander Corps
thanks for the subs yeah I guess I can I
can analyze this was uh I used in the
hustle support this was one d3 which I
don't really have a repertoire against
so if I played this there's actually
there's no e4 I guess d5 is a decent
move but it was a close Sicilian I
assume I assume this position has been
reached before Bishop h6 mean movement
so Bishop h6 I was gonna Castle here
each bar is gonna take anyway let's get
to critical moment it's like here I
wasn't sure what to do
sawfish not working how many people are
on leech s right now the 77,000
john-john's thanks for subbing oh there
is o so 9 H 5 is up there that's what I
playing takes ah so I made kind of an
intuitive decision but stockfish like
some other moves f5 I did not consider
and I missed this whole idea Bishop g5
here I felt worse
he played c4 which I thought was clever
and we basically played the sawfish line
rook to Yale apparently not good Oh 95
immediately I would take all my Queens
kind of stuck Quincy I'm just looking at
the the sawfish line I guess White's
much better here with the bishop hair
see for coming now I had potential to be
mother and then even go forward here why
it was better for a long time in the
scheme and here I was I was scared of
this because I was either gonna have to
play off six or I was actually
considering 97 the idea of allowing
takes and then I think just takes in
Keaney chains looks strange though this
would have been really difficult anyway
hope people enjoy that so the tournament
people are saying it crashed but it
looks to be underway but maybe a crashed
I don't know the page isn't loading wait
for it to load whoa it's done I said the
timer was still going to oh that's so
sad
I finished in tied for last place
because my game didn't count that's so
sad time to cry actually time to give
more money to each us to support their
surgeries there they're suffering from
growing pains the quickest five hours of
our lives yeah that was a five hour
tournament finished in I think less than
an hour it's my worst tournament
performance ever
and what to do I worked so hard to will
need to finish in a tie for last